[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
going to be a fun-filled evening
[ __ ] a little Memorial Day kit a
chatter for you that my wife hears your
[ __ ] love you
[Music]
you know what therefore if you're under
18 hang up now it's not going to be a
good night to you cop second Kentucky's
change
[Music]
it's that type of [ __ ] tonight
uncle Joey with his hoop do pillow
hairdo ready to [ __ ] rock tonight I'm
happy a few user here that's all we need
three of us and we can take over the
[ __ ] that way everybody is dilly
dallying [ __ ] around
grilling who gives a [ __ ] I did that
[ __ ] all day tomorrow's another day I
wanted to look the [ __ ] veterans
happy Memorial Day you [ __ ] something
there wasn't for you we wouldn't be here
doing bonnets you understand me because
of you we get the chance to do bung it
and act like [ __ ] [ __ ] and so on
and so forth if you're under 18 hang up
now and then going to be a good night
for you you're sitting there thinking
what do you got that's not the question
the question is what don't we got give
us a me we got water we got acid we got
MDMA here tonight Lee's looking all sad
because he knows it's going to be a
[ __ ] bad night we're going to open up
with a quick bung here to let me know
what time it is here I got three
tremendous weeds
I got [ __ ] Larry Oh Gianna respectful
Vegas periscope and we got this death on
two legs this fall by 99 I'm so hard
hitting in the kajak Lilian compared
some perennial I don't [ __ ] know
parrot smoke already
who gives a [ __ ] I already got three for
fungus and uncle Joey
got a great alum on precious time 1982
Pat Benatar at the height of her [ __ ]
career right after crimes of fashion
three four good little jams on here
Leah you ready for this bunk in here I
don't think someone is free [ __ ] 99
viewers here we go [ __ ] it's that
type of party tonight we're celebrating
for the [ __ ] veterans who can hear
there he is that beautiful [ __ ] been
on all day
look at them spotless they're about to
come out don't their bong get to the
spots come on about three let's do this
[ __ ]
through this [ __ ] suck that [ __ ]
juice there you go we go we go are you
gonna wait on you got to get those inner
workings there you go there you go
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Dylan's father already training
[ __ ] I've been talking about it
you understand me
if you can't train there ain't gonna
work out for you and you go that's a
ball off him look you said I'm [ __ ]
showing up here on a Sunday I'm a Lord's
Day cuz this [ __ ] Mary Magdalene show up
because Jesus is cave within the famine
don't worry about what I put in it this
is direct from [ __ ] Bangkok this week
our kickboxer I knew grew this Oh ler
kicked in the head like 80 [ __ ] time
he needs high THC levels to get them let
me get that bottle let me fill it up he
again you need a BB this is what this is
this is a Joel Romero need a physician
quality
[Music]
I told you I'm not showing up with
something kinky thinking we've no more
cupcakes where do I find this [ __ ] the
people I deal with the professionals
they known that don't even call me until
you got the [ __ ] that's make another
beat I want this [ __ ] that other people
bring back to the county I can't smoke
this ice I think I couldn't stop hearing
voices my mother was in the room and
she's been dead for 18 years that's the
weed I want if you don't give me that we
we can't do [ __ ] business understand
you why why why I want to go deeper than
be ain't got time it Jesus right there
[Music]
we ain't got time to be [ __ ] around
in a sentence in my jeans
oh that manly little digs is [ __ ] day
one they call me Jacques Cousteau I go
so much beep now Gentiles other than no
ever if it's a question certainly know
how to [ __ ] don't you know who Jack was
close
I wanna give you my love
oh [ __ ] paddy draw me play you come on
like a flame then you turn a cold
shoulder
what type of [ __ ] moly you unless you
got to here but something like that
you're playing becomes like this you
know those [ __ ] of the hill there we
show you a tip them with time with your
finger BAM they disappear you get pissed
up but your lucky day good you [ __ ]
you got an extra finger you don't say
[Music]
you come on like a flame then you turn a
cold shoulder fire and die we want to
train you know your turns you have the
weekend off I've done six loads know you
have it like two and a half you have
time to go watch baseball go to fun
watch oh come on you Ashley you know
quakes so clicks there you go you're
[ __ ] lumpy go stay in hand
[ __ ] this is it this is the one
that favor QE that's the one that's the
one daddy boy that's the one
finish that [ __ ] that's the one
[ __ ]
please that's the one I remember chased
me around with the lighter kind of
lightning on fire at the middle
Oh guess what I mean
just like you to say goodbye with being
dull rate when you can sing it in here
tonight dancing who the [ __ ] you think
you did you think I'd invite you to the
periscope object if we weren't showing
up with some [ __ ] goodies field only
[ __ ] is right
this week they should call it three beep
it's that type of night you know I'm
saying we don't take a night off here
since we [ __ ] leaks it like a weekend
up staying a week you start with a
handful concept
boom we'll give you that idea
we're always in training them we don't
know when the next meal is coming they
gotta eat with some funny you man Johnny
boy no Sam my Johnny domani
all laughing got it I like to disobey
Allah you know I'm sorry
forget about it what else is going on
you bad [ __ ] you want to
barbecue tomorrow or did nobody invite
you in them because you're a [ __ ]
Apple Moo hey I got the same problem
only two people invited me for the whole
summer oh [ __ ] was it today it's just
like me
oh [ __ ] but just like when they're
watching now my main man Russell
Buddhism and uh Bruce Buffer aka Jimmy
while having a back to math and had
stuff with a baby we have two [ __ ]
kids parties say I charge you not a
[ __ ]
once you have the [ __ ] children and
they have a funnies every [ __ ]
weekend you sit here going I don't have
a social life but a four-year-old we
don't do drugs and all sons if they
don't do nothing they got more parties
to go to and you better [ __ ] dream
them no mass comm no Christian mingle
they just rock the [ __ ] out ladies
are missing what [ __ ] self Jews I
mean awful woman [ __ ] Jew around by
me they are mes every person we invite
the check everybody I'm going by the
[ __ ] n do for this is who gives a [ __ ]
bring that [ __ ] come upon a
lottery ticket little [ __ ] you think you
feeling it if Sunday night is the pre
church here just trying to get the party
started loosen up a couple things for
you oh [ __ ] both of our loyalties time
oh [ __ ]
I don't want to talk about who is the
lion cuz there's too many ways to lie
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what you
ready for a bunny you looking at me
thinking save yourself Johnny how much
longer you where's our [ __ ] attach to
your hand
Joey I was hoping it'd give me a [ __ ]
taste of that Fucci don't you count me
out baby stop it
life is too short so why waste precious
time are you [ __ ] nuts and Sunday
night you thought it was my show up here
with a [ __ ] preacher it on a bag of
[ __ ] M&M [ __ ] no it's the Lord's
night [ __ ]
and I got you [ __ ] his nothing
I feel a little like math mastery in her
hand
well the other one second some show
about superheroes like a half a [ __ ]
watch a man no wonder everybody's
[ __ ] run around confused
all these little [ __ ] young [ __ ] want
to be superheroes with it
what are you gonna tell them when
they're 18 you're in no [ __ ] danger I
grew up on the killer's bronson [ __ ]
whoa could eastwood Steve McQueen
killers rocky that's why I looked up to
Luigi [ __ ] look up this the guy
that was dancing around in la-la land
that's how you want it man
now you [ __ ] anyway don't get me
[ __ ] confused it slap another one we
ready baby stop it
so why waste precious time
life is too short so why waste precious
time Larry on the [ __ ] parade love me
this is the master of entry here we go
the workplane my oh [ __ ]
little Neil Giraldo kicking it to the
next level you [ __ ] is we ready
for another bond gamma I gave eight
stars 10 minutes ago easy for this my
ideal five minutes here we go
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
negative now we this [ __ ] strong in
these [ __ ] you people think my uncle
jump this and come bulletproof at this
age I'm bullying is this should we lived
it you don't know how to [ __ ] we
disarmed his visitation
how many condoms a billion sold 11 brand
new bag we haven't even kicked Amelia
why [ __ ] around another there we go
we talked on the telephone long distance
to New Yorker room oh [ __ ]
well I didn't give me your styles I'm a
greedy [ __ ] I gotta give you some
blues what kind of present might only
use illusion you tell me - so long -
time to get dressed again the spots
around
oh yeah let's want to come look and then
I developed an allergy to [ __ ]
marijuana [ __ ] no he's getting some you
know our school bug in your on allergies
will [ __ ] you a little bit creating an
erection
life is too short so why waste precious
time I am ready good let's do this [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] it's Memorial Day
[Music]
hold on below away kick that mule kick
that mule isn't a mule kick
there you go living the mule on fire
[Music]
they go the deals on fire now
the mules on Wyatt I think your grants
are oh my god why would you whole
training is the whole [ __ ] thing
people keep talking around you little
[ __ ] pipes and little [ __ ] joints and
filters on them and then I'm gonna go
invite you to the boom-boom lounge and
you get spots and [ __ ] I'm showing up
with the mule and the best reefer in
[ __ ] town oh and one lady a one
what's a long alumna Lee needs alone put
them on the list you understand me on
the arm [ __ ] jack was this town they
showed up they got the down they got the
livers of the kidneys and they abandon
ship an hour later they put on the
American Express card don't leave home
without it you know saying excuse me
Foreman he's burping I got gas coming
out I got everything here understand
listen if Sunday night traditionally we
go deep here's one I run Sunday nights
when I was still slinging deck and
giving out [ __ ] chopsticks box my
nights with Sundays and Thursdays and
before that you included Monday because
a Monday Night Football
she only internet generationally goes
out on Monday Night Football the last
football is an excuse to get [ __ ] up
but you want to [ __ ] is that blue Pepsi
generation and [ __ ] you [ __ ] it up
Monday night was the best night of the
week everybody gave you [ __ ] dollar
beers or we had chicken wings meatball
sandwiches but you're [ __ ] up because
you stay out we had to do [ __ ] now
mondays are stronger than Fridays
Fridays and Saturdays and much of my
Thursdays when the party gets started
Friday and looking for you what happened
to him he's been out for 22 hours only
tang out with you [ __ ] amateurs
Saturday night you off for a cocktail
until the amateurs to suck your dick
they're out there getting [ __ ] up
Sunday you show up women listen you ever
seen a girl when she hasn't sucked a
dick by Sunday she
pressed its subject I haven't sucked a
meal right you ever got to eat
somebody's [ __ ] by Sunday eat their
[ __ ]
by Sunday you can depress you 103 nights
you wore your best shirt Thursday and
Friday not happen Friday Sunday night
nobody wants to go mobile so column Inc
so Sunday night you show up like [ __ ]
Sinatra even though you look like
[ __ ] me how do we intent you see I'm
sorry I'm just pitching it to you you
got to do the rest of that excuse me one
second upon some [ __ ] different music
in there reef it does have the stuff
done that's good reef eject guys you
know I will [ __ ] around I can't at this
age I'll have much time whether high and
I your feet are [ __ ] numb is it a
totally different kind of Collins
there's a totally different type of town
which understand
while we do it this way sure because
there's the only way to do that can we
do it any other way
no you got to [ __ ] yourself up what you
want do you want a cat neat if the birds
on it or you want to eat the real [ __ ]
you tell me what do you want to do
below musica
so here we are Sunday the kickoff to
Memorial Day weekend
better than you you've tuned in we got a
great podcast for you lined up oh [ __ ]
this is it a couple more buckets and
we'll start the show right we play ended
up with this right here we gotta face
those two stars we're trying that's it
there ain't gonna [ __ ] story I already
ate one eye close to it ain't custard
oh [ __ ] here we go what what oh [ __ ] -
uh the bingo or debt even if another bar
namely who wants to go back on the club
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm happy for you excuse you you [ __ ]
around all weekend you tried to you know
try to be this [ __ ] thing I've been
telling you gotta be [ __ ] ass and at
7:24 and you don't believe yet listen
it's been done I've seen it for 54 years
he's trying to tell me what I can and
what I can't pump until you understand
the other we do this [ __ ] seven at 7:24
what length
there's no length to the juice because
you're honest welcome any show business
well your [ __ ] view the troupe oh
[ __ ]
time for another fun video of death what
do you think people I love it when you
call me big papa would you do three
wasn't I should be having my baby baby
why you livin Biggie's home
[Music]
who you be with let's see what's next
[Music]
we'll do this what we're doing here is
like you ever see hot ones with the
wings is ten different types of weeds
insects and you know few we gonna do
what we came to do is that right booth
true uncut they have like they stopped
light minimal ones that's a we do now
you don't you dependent somebody's
wanted the last we're doing that's good
we find the finger so first show me I
believe these [ __ ] go oh [ __ ]
look I love it when you call me big papa
[Music]
really you hate the little one okay I
appreciate it we'll put the heavy on
compliment how really impact and if the
always what you go maybe is the juice
[ __ ] Mick McKenna
[Music]
even good answer I'm trying not to kill
myself but are you so this is the one
like maybe I'm eating it
oh my god are you [ __ ] around I can't
read that much you're breathing
[Music]
who you look what's going on you on the
whole I'm not dissing isn't look at
that's not that's bad right let me pull
another one up - oh my god is you
[ __ ] them I do not [ __ ] it up I'm
sitting oh hi we talking about Josh I
get out
show the hand biggest ones come listen
anything no not with the tongue Oh can't
even forward my lucky number don't
punish my are we gonna make it
Sheamus you still got son I'm trying
apparently we go you ain't like to
restore a [ __ ] gonna stick to the
band and I took two more oh [ __ ]
your strength [ __ ] you can't take
another one just me like immediately
start using oh [ __ ]
there's no break some life in the salmon
you want to take a break to get you to
jump me on the run spec oh yeah oh [ __ ]
you want to [ __ ] bounce uncle Joey's
in America's only uncle in the family I
took that title by myself but 18 months
ago
you [ __ ] need a real uncle and
uncle Joey's in from Philly you need
ready for the likes of this um what it's
very nice to get together with you
savages or smoke a little tooth looks
they share a couple laps on the Sunday
[ __ ] evening this is the type of
world we live in so that way you scratch
my back I scratch your [ __ ]
back we'll be back in 10 minutes
youtube.com slash Slean slash Joey Diaz
don't forget me Thursday night the
[ __ ] midweek work on this week is
that slappers 7:30
Thursday night another our all-new
trying to put the album together so I
can make you [ __ ] proud you
understand me let's do this [ __ ] ten
minutes youtube.com / c / Joey billions
is the only way to beat I love your
concept to stay black I got you